Tạng tháng 2 năm 2018, sau quả chính điều tra, tôi thập tương tình tại liệu, chính cứ hằng chăm cá mục,
chứ xí của phòng cạnh sát hình sự công an thành phố chiming và các đình vì phối hồ cùng các phương tịch kiết thật.
Nhưng vụ đã chiếc sóa thành công tụ diễn đánh bạc giữ hình thức đá gạa,
tìm tệ máy đất trường phía sau nhà không số thuộc tổ mì bốn,
khu phố mấy 2, phương hò lợi, tình phố chiming.
Đi đến nay, giờ nhau đối tượng lưu văn tấn,
xin năm 2018, phạm thình yịch xin năm 2018 và chỉ lên dương.
xin năm 2018, cùng cứ chú tệ phương hò lợi,
cơm đầu tụi nhiều con bạc tự cơ địa phương khác đến thăm ra sát hả?
Với số tình lên đến hẳng trong trộn đồng, tại thư điểm phá an,
đã bắt có tăng bủ 15 đổi tượng đăng tổ chức đánh bạc và đánh bạc,
tu dưới hơn 8 trộn đồng, 3 con gà ná, 3 mit tám địa thuải dự động,
3,5 xe gần máy, 2 ổ tổ cùng nhiều vật trường khác có lưu quán.
Hẹn cơ đối tượng đã được dưới phòng cạnh giác hình sự để tốt đổ trên làm sáo vị trí,
bai trò và sử liên nghiêm theo quý định của pháp lột.